[موسيقى]
هنا الكبير جدا خارج القطاعه النفط والغاز
وخاصه في مجال التكنولوجيا لان العقوبات
اكثرها اثر انها كانت على قطاع المالي
وحيث وقطعتها حوالي كل بنوك الروسيه من
النظام السويفت والحاولات الدوليه وكذلك
الحظر على التكنولوجيا ايضا انتشر بشكل
كبير واضر بشكل كبير
بروسيا وسيكون اكثر اضرارا خاصه عقوبات
القديمه لان روسيا تجد من الصعوبه
سراج اي شيء قد يعتبر من الاستخدامات
الثنائيه الاستخدامات المدنيه وهذا اثر
على قطاع السيارات ومجالات كثيره
مجالات كثيره من الاقتصاد بالتالي باتت
اساسيه اما
الاشخاص او الشركات غير القادرين على
الوصول الى احدث التكنولوجيا او المنتجات
التكنولوجيه او المنتجات الاستهلاكيه
وكان هذا ربما هو اكبر انحدار او اثر فيما
يخص التجاره مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي اوروبا الحكومه تستمر
بالحديث عن
خططهم
لما سمى بتوطين الانتاج
[موسيقى]
يمكن نطر الامر من جانبين اولا ان الاموال
التي كسبتها روسيا من تصدير السلعه الى
اوروبا خاصه النفط والغاز والفحم وماده
اخرى
كلها فرضت عليه العقوبات بشكل بطيء جدا
لانه عليها تتكيف فيما يخص ايجاد المصادر
فمثلا في المعاضي روسيا كسبت حوالي
280 مليار دولار
مقارنه ب 190 في العام الذي قبله والكثير
من ذلك من اوروبا
عبر
ساعد في دعم الاقتصاد وهذه باتت من
المسائل التي اصبحت سريه فلا يعطون
معلومات حول اين انفقت هذه الاموال الكثير
منها بالتاكيد على الدعم العسكري وهذا امر
واضح وحتمي ولكن ايضا
الكثير منه ايضا الى الدعم للوظائف في بعض
المجالات اللي دعمي البرامج الاجتماعيه
مثل الرعايه الصحيه والخدمات العامه
[موسيقى]